where's the guys walking back to back
although Jillian thinks
all the things this episode are to
inaudible is the best way to read books
because then you're not to read them
they are audiobooks and you can get the
app it's the audible app download over
180,000 titles across all genres well
it's amazing first book is not on me
it's on Jenna she's gonna buy your first
book I will podcast dog named Thor I got
this one / Jenna - your first book I
want to listen to Tyler Oakley's binge
on Hanah book you just got the real one
I know but doesn't he read it I know
it's an audio copy of it in his voice
that I'm kind of interested in huh yeah
that actually does sound good right
like what authors read their own books
it's pretty dope there's a lot of that
inaudible by the way yeah like how does
Harry Potter get down to hell
by walking JK Rowling I told the judge I
told that joke and we both like Sarah
dying I was dying it's not our joke
though it's from reddit are jokes yes I
do some are jokes well we recently got
back from New York yeah and this week
has been a little nuts just kind of
getting back into the swing of
everything yeah I almost came down with
like a head cold because I was so
exhausted yeah you like didn't sleep for
the majority of the week yeah I didn't
sleep for basically a week and I can't
really do that to my body anymore
because I'm not like 20 and I start to
feel the ramifications of not sleeping
so had a lot of gatorade and some good
naps and feeling my doctor back to
normal the other unveiling of the wax
figure was absolutely incredible we have
a video that we're gonna put somewhere
right yes yeah yeah hopefully on it was
just the most real thing ever I think
the weird it honestly to be perfectly
honest the weirdest part of the whole
thing is seeing like an external version
of what you look like
yeah you got a mirror reflection yeah
you walk around you're like oh that's
[ __ ] look like alright [ __ ] but I
side from the obvious of how it moves
just an incredible honor and it was
amazing to be there and see daddy very
cool
it was it was one of those things where
you're looking at it but you're not
quite sure if you believe it yeah
exactly and her makeup honestly looks
better than I've ever done my own makeup
so really just like you know they they
face tuned you yeah you learn the best
version of you and it's physical it's
not picture right and when I see like
she has her own Twitter account and show
like tweet out pictures and then people
will tag me like on Instagram and stuff
when they go see her and it looks like
me in a picture like I'll see it in my
life
tag pictures like when was that oh yeah
[ __ ] it's not me but it is me but it's
not me this is very wild they were so
happy to have you there and like have
you be part I mean I thought it was just
so beyond smart for them to do what
they're doing great with the internet
thing but not only that it's like yours
is I mean yours is top notch like you
can see as they get newer they get like
cleaner and like was scarier real you
know yeah so yours is like way up there
but the interactive function about how
it takes selfies with the visitors of
the museum it's like so smart and it
goes right into social media it's like
exactly the step in the right direction
that they need to know exactly and well
my mom came with us which was very nice
to have legend crushed it the entire
time we were there
she brought a picture with her of me
when I was in like 7th or 8th grade we
went to London and we had gone to that
Madame Tussauds and I remember that I
think that one was probably one of my
first experiences going to a wax museum
and like none of it was very interactive
like the the best that you could get was
sort of life they would be in a pose
that lent itself to taking a picture
with them so she brought a picture of
her of me sitting next to like somebody
I don't even know who was oh yeah I
forgot it was two but different yeah to
see how far they've come in terms of
making them more interactive because as
like living in LA of how
lot of friends come and one of the only
things they want to do is go to that wax
museum we're doing in Hollywood so I've
been there like seven [ __ ] times and
the most fun ones that are there are the
ones that are like interactive like you
can stand next to Tiger Woods or
whatever pretend you're golfing or you
can look actually hit a ball or you know
sort of Nicki Minaj yeah God so they
have made them more interactive but the
way that they made mine interactive was
pretty smart and pretty cool embracement
and there's no other one like that no
bigger or anywhere no and it was cool I
mean obviously was insane like going
into the museum and seeing the unveiling
and looking at your figure especially
with you there but it was even cooler
after we we took a tour of the entire
Museum in New York they gave us a tour
yeah so you got to see and that was my
first time at Baptist that's why I got
to see what it was and what I was like
and all the figures and then we circled
around back two years and I was like
damn like this is cool because you had
your own exhibit it had some screens
behind you with your old videos playing
and it's just it was just like very
smart very cool to be a part of and
obviously so proud of you to see that
happen and there's nothing like that I
don't think we've ever experienced or
ever will experience jail very cool
just once in a lifetime for sure yeah
insane yeah um so that's why we were
gone and not sleeping yeah yeah and
we're gearing up to go to Tokyo yeah
which is quite a life experience
yeah uh you guys might have seen Jin
this video this last week where we kind
of just try to learn Japanese on the
Internet and although we were kind of
goofing around and having fun with it it
really was like the first kind of step
we've taken to priming ourselves for the
culture shock both of the language and
the you know what the customs know is
that you call it when the way you act
just how society works and where were
100% like we're looking things up like
we're getting ourselves ready because we
know it's going to be different and I'm
expecting quite an experience you know
I'm expecting a big learning curve too
yeah no matter how much we learn we're
gonna have to I have been to the airport
and to the moon yeah is there just one
Airport in Tokyo just well it's the
biggest I think I think it's the biggest
airport I think it's Narada is what most
people fly into is the one that I flew
into um yeah I've been to the airport
and I guess I didn't really think about
it then because we were catching a
flight to Singapore which is in my
opinion a little bit less of a culture
shock because almost everybody's
speaking English and you know it's kind
of not quite the same as Japan obviously
but I didn't even think about it while
we're at the airport that like maybe
there would be a language barrier or
anything like that and there really
wasn't because you don't need to know
especially in airports they do a good
job of putting things in a lot of
languages yes especially English for
most airports that I've been to there's
always like a thing in English even by
even Bali we could get around that
airport um so I never even thought about
it when I was there but then as you're
like looking up different things in
Tokyo you're like okay here's some
things that are probably important that
I would never think of like just
understanding the symbol for like where
the woman's bathroom is or like just
learning the currency so that you know
how to pay for things just like basic
things that you should understand or to
get around and once you start going down
that rabbit hole it does become kind of
daunting but I thanks to the internet
obviously I'm now aware that a lot of
people speak English and at least know
basic things like hello and please you
know it can help help me and that the
culture is there very much understanding
of tourists and Tokyo especially since
there's a lot of tourists that go there
they're more than willing to help you
and have no problem if you don't speak
Japanese they want to help you anyways
which is very like comforting to predict
you know but we're also you know we're
going there it would be YouTube FanFest
but I guess they've since changed it to
not a full-blown event because for those
view that have you know medicine
Australia or Singapore or any of the
YouTube fan fests that we've done it's
you know run by the same guys we like
them a lot we've really good
relationship with them and you basically
go you do like a live show you do a
meet-and-greet and then you know a
couple other things maybe and then you
go home so they invited us to Japan and
of course I was like sign me up
yes please I would love to go to Tokyo
but they sort of took out the show
aspect of it I think and I'm sort of
just giving a talk yeah well I think
it's a good creator thing yeah like
you're doing a creative workshop isn't
it it means I'm gonna mean gree yeah so
there's no stage performance like there
normally would so I imagine for those
days when we're doing that we'll have
someone helping us get around yeah we'll
have someone from the fit me we have
like a day or two or like a day and a
half where we'll be free on our own so
it's not gonna be the biggest seal we're
not trying to like do a bunch of stuff
yeah although my brother I was good to
say like when you were facing me I was
like you telling your owners me because
he's been there he lives he has been to
Japan um but he didn't spend a lot of
time in Tokyo he spent time in like
different of other cities like a more
rural yeah yeah um so it was much more
difficult to navigate than Tokyo you
sure for sure yeah because most people
when they're visiting Japan they're in
bigger cities for the most part in them
yeah my brother was just in it where you
know 98% of the population is Japanese
for sure than 1% is other Asian
countries and then like point 5 percent
like 0.01 percent is like tourists you
know
yeah so I've been watching a lot of
YouTube videos which is like the coolest
thing in the whole world so cool having
this tool to just like learn anything we
want yeah not only can you learn the
language but you can learn the culture
culture there's there's certain things
that I'm honestly nervous about what are
you nervous about I'm nervous about
getting yelled at
for for being rude on accident I don't
want to be rude yeah but I feel like you
know I always do my best as do a lot of
normal people to just not be rude right
but when you don't really know what's
rude and if you're doing something
that's offensive without knowing that
like that's that scares me like you know
apparently you're not supposed to ever
get take take out or take away food or
boxed up to go when you're eating
because I just want various yeah and
then you know if you're making too much
noise in a certain place or you're on
your phone in the wrong place like all
these things I feel like I'm very prone
to doing wrong and you know we're gonna
continue to watch videos and and prepare
ourselves but I know that there's this
gonna be you know that one time when I
do something and just get yelled at by
someone and I'm not looking forward to
it but I think you're gonna be more than
okay and I would like to shout out the
particular youtuber that I've been
watching a lot of videos of is Rachel
and Jun yeah they'd kill it
they'd [ __ ] kill it she's an American
living in Japan she commented on your
video oh yeah she's super husband um
yeah she'll you know just give you an
Americans perspective about the culture
and you know how to not offend people
and I've also watched her ones from
Japanese to English but I go being like
all right when you're in America here's
some things you need to know damn you're
right I never would like would have told
someone to think about it that's true
what cuz they'd never been to the the
other place right so well she's like
when someone sees this it's polite to
say bless you and I'm like that's
something I would never even think about
what do you do if you sneeze in Japan I
don't know [ __ ] maybe you don't say
bless you I'm just not gonna sneeze I
think you're gonna be more than if I
feel as these coming on I'm gonna panic
and like blackout oh my god dude I do
look forward to eating all the sushi I
can fit in my body though I know I'm
that I'm a little nervous for food to be
honest because as a lot of people know
in your life some vlogs and stuff you've
been about hardcore vegan for about
three and a half months yeah no you have
gotten back into it so that
that does not make travelling easy let
alone traveling to a place where you
can't speak the language so I mean it's
okay because I know I can eat miso
edamame right there are vegetarian
restaurants in Tokyo but not many Sam is
like [ __ ] but you just need to be a
vegetarian restaurant though in order
for me to find yeah I mean you know how
to navigate food that you can eat to get
to what you can't eat but basically
whenever I order sushi to the house you
know what you like and get rice you can
get vegetables these you get miso soup
and edamame and those are all things are
they're gonna have their but you know
even if we go to like some place because
we're starving and they only have sushi
you just get a bowl of rice you mean
like worst calm source you're going to
have sustenance but no it's absolutely a
challenge for both of us because the
gluten-free thing is not easy there's
sauces all over the place and sound like
you know but well I do know from Rachael
and June's videos that like you can't
really ask for a lot of modifications to
your meal which is like what Julian
lives on like hey can you take out this
and add this please because or else I
can't eat it my body will attack itself
but I think you're gonna be good in
terms of just surviving on sushi yeah
something literally all you want to eat
anyway yeah I mean I would say that's
one of the toughest things about being
gluten free and having celiac disease is
that whenever I do need to make
modifications or ask for special
requests I know how it comes off like
I'm aware that it comes off as picky and
as almost insulting to the chef and the
restaurant for not having something that
I'd like already so there's this place
in you know over the hill in Santa
Monica it's called father's office it's
a burger joint yeah and they're their
thing there's they will not give you any
sort of modifications no matter what
like you eat the burger the way they
give it and I get it I understand where
they're coming from it's like they're
prideful in their product they don't
want to deal with nitpickers and that's
not what I want to come off as but I
have to sometimes and like that place is
so frustrating because everyone raves
about how good the burgers are and like
this place is the size of a closet I've
never actually been in there anymore
but everyone's always like Oh Julian
you're from Santa Monica you every
father's office is incredible like
people won't shut up about it honestly
and to know that you can literally never
go have a burger there because there are
a fuse to make modifications is pretty
insulting yeah but I mean you know at
you know devil's advocate here you're a
you're a waiter or yours maybe you're
the guy who created files on yes you
wanna yeah you want to create an
environment where no [ __ ] is
tolerant no people who want to nitpick
and stuff like that like I get it and I
don't mean to be part of that but I do
right but I mean honestly I feel like my
I've had such a decent like experience
with sushi in terms of like I've eaten
sushi had a lot of different places for
a lot of years and I know my way around
you know even the Japanese terms of most
sushi that I II should be okay you know
and like I'm I'm a well we're I'm well
aware of like we're well even just on
that topic though about how like you get
it you're a chef you don't want to
modify your food like think of we've
been to Las Vegas in the past to Gordon
Ramsay's burger place yes we didn't
actually eat there because it was too
late they were closed yeah they were
closing in like 10 minutes
but Julian had asked like the waiter or
somebody we were we like charges walked
up and look at the menu and he was like
hey B you guys have any gluten-free buns
here or anything like that yeah and she
goes like hold on and rain and got the
manager and I was like oh [ __ ] what's
him yeah like he's like sorry first of
all we're closed
yeah but second of all you know we take
gluten free very seriously we take all
dietary needs very seriously he like
almost reassured you to like a
ridiculous point that you're more than
safe eating there and this is a
restaurant owned by Gordon Ramsay murder
arguably one of the most famous chefs in
the world so we get it father's office
or other restaurants that you don't make
modifications because you you don't want
to compromise the integrity of your
product of what you made but think of
somebody on an even bigger scale and
what they do in tort in order to not
compromise their products in astute
point you know a really good point and
like Jay can attest you can attest this
like for the longest time when we would
we would watch Gordon Ramsay shows for
years
together and every single time I love
him his amazing negative but I love him
too
every single time I watched a show with
it was master Schaffer Hell's Kitchen or
whatever whatever literally Kitchen
Nightmares I would always just have this
kind of like limited sense of enjoyment
where I could enjoy the show as an
audience member and watch it but I could
never really imagined meeting him and
not offending him I always always always
figured you know if I were to have to
come face-to-face as Gordon Ramsay and
tell him hey this lovely creation you
made looks amazing I can't eat this part
that like I would that terrifies me to
death but then I've since like done
research and found that Gordon Ramsay is
actually one of the most like solid and
caring proponents of dietary you know
needs and restrictions at restaurants
and that made me so happy to think about
and we have we experienced the firsthand
when we went to Burger and past them and
they were so and also at the the palms
chef Barry's as his name's Barry what
what's that I don't remember the name of
the restaurant come on blanket nine
state Steakhouse so we went there
because we were doing an event at the
Palms ghosts club or bodega right yes he
did the same thing he came over and was
like are there any dietary restrictions
and joy was like absolutely and he bent
over back there he was like ooh I got it
the richest things like delicious take
it eat but not salads like he brought me
good [ __ ] he brought me risotto like and
that's that's so it like exciting and
encouraging to know that like really
high level respected chefs are taking
things like that seriously right no but
I mean the good part about going to a
foreign country when the two of us
combined usually have an interesting
time as it is v in America and were the
two finding like but it's never a
problem even tonight we're gonna take
bread out to dinner for his birthday
happy birthday bread um and he's like I
just want to go somewhere where you guys
can eat like you we could totally eat
anywhere yeah we figured out
but is sometimes a little bit of a
challenge I think for you more than for
me because for some reason people
understand that like you know I'm not
going to eat meat or like animal
products so like I can eat vegetables
and rice and grains and whatever but for
celiac I feel like a lot of people don't
understand they're like well why don't
you just take the bread off and you know
scrape it off like it's not that's okay
right yeah it's not it's really not you
get me sick
yeah so um I think at least when we go
to Japan and to other places in the
future it's it's gonna be a little bit
much better than it has been in the past
for you because Tokyo especially like
alright so much of that stuff already
you eat and you know how to eat it yeah
without getting sick and a lot of their
food just is [ __ ] really it's like
rice base yep and I can have all the
fish in the world and you can't so you
can go to like a fish market and just
get fish you know that right yeah
she's tried to do that here he'll try
and get like sushi grade fish and then
just eat it but it's not this yeah cuz I
haven't gone to the right places but
there yeah I think in addition to you
know watching YouTube videos to prepare
myself for the food and everything
I might download an audiobook uh-huh on
the audible.com slash Jenna and you can
get your free audiobook so if you're
going to Japan or wherever and you want
to learn about it and you want someone
to read it to you while you do other
things go to audible honorable is the
best way to listen to audiobooks on the
go on your app on the iPhone Android on
the computer wherever you are you get
your first book for free on us audible
podcast.com slash Jetta it's worth
checking out honestly there's a lot of
ways to read books and you know now a
days audiobooks are our thing now
they're popular and they're a good way
to ingest information while also not
sitting in more you know looking at the
pages of a book and audible does it so
well their app
clean the system is so simple you need
to buy books you get a book you download
right to your phone you pick it up right
where you left off just by pressing play
long car rides telling you guys that
it's really nice it'll get you back into
read and for those of you who who used
to read and don't really read time I've
got inaudible yeah I'm still I only
showing ya ready player one I've been
going slowly actually was talking to
Chris last night he's really good tutors
reading it too so it's great stuff check
out audible audible podcast.com slash
Jenna first free book but ya know I'm I
think that you and I are both going to
have an easier time than we're expecting
getting food and it's going to be a
process and a learning situation but it
will be fun and I'm excited to eat sushi
man I've heard people from people who
have been to Japan like you don't know
what sushi is until you've literally
been excited about that I know I'm
really excited to I don't think we will
get a spot at Giro's restaurant it's
it's okay it's alright you're gonna be
alright
you know okay - sorry drew we have I
have downloaded a bunch of apps and like
you have different ways of learning
Japanese so you have a little bit a high
L cos I'm us because I must good morning
formal formal Kyle gozaimasu konnichiwa
does Emma Nietzsche long ago this is a
good day potty knee no no potty potty
potty Disney party party party
arigato gozaimasu means like thank you
formal formal domo arigato gozaimasu is
like thank you thank you take you take
you thank you
so we're gonna be saying the whole time
like a nice sari most formal way you
could say thank you if someone did
something like really really nice
arigato because I'm up yeah
please more sushi or if if you were
Julian and me and I was like Julian pass
me the remote here there's me I just got
Domo like thank you but thanks yeah
thanks come on come on don't listen then
I was stealing my back everything dumb
on my amount um but yeah I think we're
gonna be all ready we should be good
uh what's great is that we think you
plan on blogging to like you'll bring
your blog camera
we [ __ ] hurt you I really do because
remember we were sitting like a long
time ago look I don't think I haven't
taken like an actual vacation and since
I've started YouTube you know we'll go
to Big Bear or somewhere close where we
can drive with the dogs like that's my
idea of a vacation I don't want to get
on a plane and go somewhere but yeah
that stresses me out but we are talking
like in the future if we ever like
decided to take a vacation and go
somewhere like what's your number one
bucket list place and we both said Japan
like I would just I don't I don't really
want to go to a beach and like lay
around and get you're off I went on a
[ __ ] Tokyo Japan never we both said
that no we did which is the craziest
thing that we got you know but you got
this offer to go to fan fest them its
Tokyo and it's just insane and so we'll
be at the YouTube space for a little bit
in Tokyo yeah that's crazy I know and
I've met a couple Japanese youtubers in
the past yeah and one of them I can't
remember his name but he's a beatboxer
and he's really great but when I met him
he had a translator I met him at the
YouTube space la yeah yeah and he was so
sweet but like he would say something
and that his translator would say it to
me and I would say to exchange letters
translator say to him so we were like
standing like laughing like you know
nice to me do that like but there was
this other person
it's like talking for us but he was a
great guy you know they killed it over
there whoo it's like yeah anytime the
UFC is an event Japan there's that
little girl with her crazy pens yeah I'm
a big fan of all UFC translators well
the tall white dude who's amazing at
translating Portuguese he is very
impressive and then a little the young
Japanese girl who has her she has these
pens with like flowers on the end of it
she always has her pens with her and
she's just lightning fast at translating
English to Japanese well that's like an
incredible amount of pressure
translating in itself because if you're
just a translator anywhere on the street
doing [ __ ] where no one's watching
you're just translating to different
people you're worried about getting
things right you worried about offending
them you worried about making me go
smoothly when you're on TV you're on
pay-per-view and this is like the
cameras in your face you're literally
translating a fighter to a commentator
to make
be another fighter right like that's
your right that's like such crazy
pressure yeah and they say so cool and
just nail and they like bare mallet um
when we first got invited I was sort of
wondering why because I know there's
like a population of Americans or you
know but whatever that live in Japan
that aren't Japanese of our native
English speakers but that what was his
name from Google that lives in Japan I
can't my bears a yeah Justin David or
something I'm like it's I'm like
blanking non-stop today I got I got his
name on Becky he works for Google and
lives in Japan and has for a long time
and he sort of explained it to me that
you know how you would watch something
from another culture to try and
understand their culture yeah and that
people that speak Japanese maybe would
watch my videos to try and understand
American but you never really thought of
it never thought about it [ __ ] blew
my mind when he said that I'm like wow
wow oh wow [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] Wow jump [ __ ]
that's also why I really like watching
Rachel and Jun's video I know there's a
eat your kimchi there they live in South
Korea but it's the same thing like I
love watching their videos because I
want to know your perspective on living
in a foreign country because out of the
[ __ ] balls do it sure for sure that's
scary
it is scary it's commenting it's
daunting to think about that we're going
to Japan period like but it's also so
daunting to think about the millions of
people that move to America without a
clue of like how do I speak this
language how do I'm you know kind of
lost on the culture I don't I don't
understand and millions of people do it
all the time like without fear they're
like [ __ ] it man we're going what I know
what we're doing we're just gonna
[ __ ] go well not only are we not
those people but we're going anybody
yeah and I mean like the internet is our
tool and we're going to use it as much
as we can but like I said going there
and experiencing it is going to be the
biggest thing yeah a couple of really
good apps although everyone in the
comments of that video was like download
this app called duolingo which looked
really great and awesome except
I didn't offer Japanese do you know they
only offer well at least in the app they
only offered like that's crazy manse
languages and you know like some Dutch
or something in there but yeah stay his
name is David our YouTube contact in
Japan he lives in Japan yeah six fluent
Japanese crazy crazy [ __ ] crazy um
yeah
what about like well duolingo is like
for dentist on right like you're
learning a language yeah so that's like
you pay the course and I think so I mean
I took eight years of Spanish you took a
lot of Spanish yes Spanish is not like
the most taxing on your brain not learn
right John Welty English yeah I took one
year of Russian and it took me two weeks
to learn the Cyrillic alphabet yeah it
was very difficult just to learn how to
write it's cuz just because Spanish
isn't really a foreign language
it's a Romance language like English
Spanish yeah well but it's also not
formed because it's amongst us every day
like it's a train on here people
speaking Japanese well in California for
sure yes absolutely look for the coolest
part when I was listening to Rachel talk
about how you know the more rural parts
of Japan like some of these people
because most of the population is
Japanese and then the other 1% is other
Asian countries they're not like tiny
tiny tiny minority is anyone that's not
yes Japanese Chinese whatever um that it
is difficult and that sometimes the
Japanese are a little like you know like
what you might do might be rude whereas
in America we have so many different
cultures and so many different people
living here from different cultures that
were kind of lacks about like you know
you're not really gonna the balance is
different yeah it is you're right um I
forgot I was gonna say it anyways yeah
yeah and you definitely don't want to go
over there and be rude but I think we're
gonna be okay as long as very topia yeah
it's not like a week to explore we have
a couple days and then we're doing the
event and then we're leaving it's like
yeah well there's no possible way that
in a couple of weeks we can learn how to
read write and speak
no focus on the functional stuff and for
sure um I like I should talk to my
brother more because my brother is like
six five he looks you know lies about as
about as the foreigners you can get into
so foreign um I would like to know his
experience a little bit more because I'm
sure he'll tell it first of all in the
most hysterical story you've ever heard
in your life because my brother is an
incredible storyteller
um but yeah I would usually know sort of
what his experiences yeah we should talk
to him the moment you face him in the
other day that was the first thing I
thought so you gotta talk to him about
Japan cuz I know he's been there yeah
yeah I mean I'm excited I'm nervous
should be fun we have two more podcasts
before Japan which we are we we we leave
what do your day I think the 15
something like that so we'll see you
guys at least once more before we yeah
to Japan but yeah it's going to be an
interesting process both getting ready
and going and doing it and with our
special dietary means happiness that's
the beauty of vlogs you have to
experience it through our eyes right and
we if we find cool stuff to do
especially if you are celiac or vegan we
will more than let you know that's what
like I said that's how we find [ __ ]
right we remember when we're in Ireland
and you had found like someone's blog
like travel blog I'm like writing about
gluten-free places yeah I was posted on
the gluten-free subreddit right like if
ever you travel to a place and you are
celiac vegan you're any sort of like
dietary yeah
you have restrictions like just sharing
it with other people is so help so huge
you may think it's not gonna get seen
but it is it does you'd like even if you
don't comment on it or like give it a
thumbs up depending on where it is like
it's so helpful just to be able to
Google like anywhere that we go to eat
yeah I Google like what are my vegan
options at this place and it tells you
exactly how to order it so to those
people out there in the world these are
injury-time writing that you the really
beyond or the people who run Instagram
accounts specific to that stuff I
thought
Oh to Instagram accounts for New York
gluten-free New York one is called GF
girls NYC any other was called [ __ ]
be gluten-free and that's my favorite
one I went to college or burning Valley
and she wins a great account but she
literally goes with all around New York
City finding all these different spots
Muslim Manhattan but they and I'm always
just like looking at her Instagram
watching I lived in here and then when
we go to New York I'm like okay well I
have this like after this exactly for
what is our neighborhood you're in now
that's I mean that's one of the coolest
things about living in 2015 with a
dietary restriction is that you're not
alone and you're not only not alone but
you're literally a click away from
finding other people's entire
experiences we're not doing what you
want to do exactly and I haven't quite
gone down the hole yet to see if there
are any English blogs about stuff like
that in Tokyo but I'm hoping that we
will find them and I'm hoping that
they're great yeah
and that's Africa I'm gonna try my best
to tell you my honest experience and I'm
sure Julian will as well although I feel
like years is just going to be about
sushi and how is it abroad from Japan's
me a lot is not a sushi bargain I'm
excited to eat [ __ ] I want to see if
they have any different fruits and
vegetables this is how like how much I
have not gotten around to looking
everything up yet but like when we were
in Bali they had that thing so much kuru
are snake fruit which was tasting like
Gatorade of Gatorade was a fruit yeah it
was sort of a mix between like an apple
and a melon sort of yeah it was that he
was like an apple yeah no [ __ ] so
good it was like it was not an excuse II
wet sort of fruit it was sort of like it
had like a dry consistency when you
spill peeled off this it wasn't you see
er wet but it made your mouth wet Oh God
but like I want to eat some Tomatoes
roots or vegetables in Japan that I'm
like hi excuse me what is this and
they'll be like it's blow up on me like
[ __ ] it
um can I eat it it's ba ba ba all right
um can you put it my mouth put it in my
mouth that's not rare just place it in
my mouth
it but yeah I'm excited and we've out
we've also talked about the fact that I
know that our sizes are totally
different like you you would need
[ __ ] my extra large I would need at
least an extra large if I wanted to buy
like a t-shirt or anything can I just
buy Japanese size things and just
squeeze them on my body make it work I
wouldn't be a puss make it work I think
it would look make things worse um there
is I am like I don't go places looking
forward to shopping but I'll tell you
one thing if we can get a little you
know Japan
I watched shopping and yeah I want
everything to when I was nine most
clothes for Italian girl my god
next level when I was uh in high school
playing baseball um there was a set of
catchers gear that no one had except for
like Jorge Posada right like it was Nike
catchers Garrett had the titanium mask
and I could you don't sell any or it's
like only the pros get it but Nike JP
had a look like of it would no one else
had and of course I got the real thing
because that's how I roll I got it off
Craigslist from a guy in Michigan
tonight uh and I still have it cuz it's
amazing but yeah Nike JP was so ahead of
the time I'm just I'm kind of itching to
do some shopping Japan man I mean the
grass is always greener because Rachel
and Jun will tell you that you can't get
American things there but you can get
really great Japanese things that's all
I want you know I can go back here for
American things or I'll just stay there
we can get Italian Greyhound clothing
with legit I know that's what I'm saying
we ordered Kermit that turtleneck from
that store I still don't even know how
you did that well yeah
funny story I mean you told me you like
you showed me this website when we first
met they make the most incredible
Italian Greyhound clothing website from
Japan and she was like this she would
literally browse it all day knowing that
she couldn't get any external shipped to
the States
so I was like okay I know you I'm
getting you for your birthday I'm
getting Kermit some authentic [ __ ]
Japanese clothing and I basically just
contacted them and got him to ship it to
us but we should find their warehouse
yeah they're called IG works
IG works and IG - work
not but like if you ever find pictures
from that like website some of them are
on like Tumblr and Pinterest like where
can i buy this and I'm like oh girl you
don't even know like they make these
incredible [ __ ] like they like furry
Jack I'm not like shitty fur coats for
dogs like they're [ __ ] elegant they
fit the Italian Greyhound body they make
em for their BOTS like it's crazy and
they make those like things that Kermit
hates like he hates anything on his skin
or he doesn't Picchu Stargate it to I
don't know why they don't like weird
we're just want to keep them warm I know
you will you'd think that they would
appreciate having an external layer of
warmth on them no they want to be naked
and then dig at your stomach so they can
get in your shirt they want to be in
your shirt well they're weird [ __ ]
shot yeah anyways anyways thank you guys
for hanging out for another podcast yeah
thanks for letting us have a more chill
relax yeah past this week sometimes
these are really nice yeah it's nice to
have a little talking podcasting it's
nice to just like not do anything but
also be entertained you know like just
by conversation which you can do with
audible you knew that was coming you do
that it's good audible never God makes
me laugh though a Hanukkah podcast.com
slash Jenna get your free audiobook with
audible and you can also download the
app trust me it's great and also tweet
us your experiences with audible because
they're good peeps and they got a great
product yeah and thank you for
sponsoring us audible if you audible
appreciate the support um thanks for
watching thanks for listening
we love you guys don't see it it's me oh
yeah good